- welcome to Scandinavia with a strong
friendship yes yes but your story
started with a horrifying event and I
wonder if we could start with that if
you can take us back Jennifer - to this
summer day in summer night in 1984 I had
gone to bed early that night and
sometime around three o'clock in the
morning I heard a noise in my bedroom
and when I looked to the left side of my
bed I noticed a person's head I could
hear him moving around on the carpet so
I said who is that who's there and at
that moment a man quickly jumped up and
jumped on me and I screamed and he
covered my mouth with a gloved hand and
put a knife to my throat and told me to
shut up he'd kill me so I tried to offer
him my car and my credit cards and my
money that I wouldn't call the police he
could just leave and that's when he told
me he didn't want my money and I knew
that I knew what was gonna happen
I knew I was gonna be raped but what you
don't know is are you gonna die I
decided at that moment that I wouldn't
die there that somehow there had to be a
way to live and if there was a way to
live I was gonna figure it out
but while I was trying to figure it out
I was gonna pay attention to what this
person looked like because when I lived
I was going to make sure he was found
and he would he would be put in prison
forever and you managed to give a very
good description and that description
fitted your face yes and I wonder what
you when you heard that the police were
looking for you because you worked in a
nearby restaurant right yes what what
did you do then you know my mother
boyfriend
tell me sir Ron the cops are looking for
you I said for what and he told me for
three I said I haven't committed such a
crime and once I entered the police
department you know I identified myself
and I was approached and they identified
themselves so they took me upstairs and
interrogated me you know that's me my
whereabouts from this night course I at
the time I was a very young man 21 years
old and at that time you know I was a
party guy you know I like to go out and
have a good time and I was on the
weekend and that's what I've done I went
out to the dance club and dance you know
so I got my weekends confused and so
they thought I was lying so I said why
you telling a lie we got you so I said
well whatever so you never got to leave
that place no when they had when they
had caught the guy and they get they day
they sentenced him to life were you did
you feel some kind of revenge did you
feel happy about that or how did you
feel about that well I felt very happy I
mean yes revenge I hated him I mean he
and not only raped me but he had raped a
woman within an hour after me and so I
felt I needed to get him off the streets
I needed to protect the other women in
the community and so when they sentenced
him to life in 50 years it was actually
based on you identifying him in the line
what was base laughing line you can see
in the movie it was based on a composite
sketch that I helped the police do that
led to a suspect that led to a
photograph lineup that led to a physical
lineup and I was able to pick him out
every time do you remember standing in
that line and understanding that you
were identified when I stepped up you
know I got real nervous and why I don't
know but I was really nervous my legs
were trembling you know because I never
put in been put in a situation like that
so I just when she wrote it down told
the detective he walked over and showed
it to my attorney
my attorney he dropped his head once he
dropped his head I knew I had been
selected so I stepped back and that was
it the solitude after serving some some
of the time another prisoner came to
prison called Bobby Poole yes and you
became suspicious yes I was a walking in
the prison down a tunnel